yo
welcome to an episode of get close i am
your co-host gio and i'm bart
and you know like a lot of people when
they look at us right they go oh man
they're hot
that's what they say when they see me
sure but they go oh man it's a really
cool life but not everyone
has like a just upward line right
everyone has been a loser in their life
yeah everyone has been
good at something yeah bad at something
yeah so one of the things that i was
thinking about and i just kind of wanted
to explore our past
is uh what were
your i'm still a loser i know but so
think even more illusory oh man what
what what job did you perform the best
at like you're like man when i had this
job i freaking crushed it and what job
were you like dude i was literally the
shittiest employee and i am surprised he
didn't fire me sooner
i've never been a shitty employee yeah
right no i swear to god okay okay okay
um so i've never really had more than
two jobs like actual jobs okay so i
worked at the bookstore slash
um coffee let's say even um non-paying
jobs
like i was the class historian and man i
[ __ ] it all up like go down to second
grade you know what i mean
i was never that that much of a fuck-up
so let me how are you not more
successful now how'd you end up with me
that's what i asked myself every goddamn
morning if you crush it at every single
job you should be with elon musk so
no not that i so can i explain goddammit
are you asking me a question i'm gonna
do a bad job right now
i'm about to [ __ ] kick you with this
is my foot dirty oh you're lucky it's
clean finally um so can i explain myself
okay so i've only had two jobs right
so the first one it was at a at a
textbook college tech book text book
store
uh on the off season it was like
primarily a coffee shop slash
um juice bar okay my second job so i
worked there like the first job maybe
about
two years
uh full time
part time sorry
full time i don't remember i'm sorry you
don't even know the difference between
the two yeah i think it was full-time i
think it was full-time um and then once
i graduated college and when i was kind
of like about to wrap up college i was
working at a bank and then i was working
my way up right
we also interned at universal music
yeah but that's not like a
so that was so short i said even class
historians i know but i didn't suck at
any of it i mean obviously i didn't get
hired because i probably didn't i didn't
let's examine that because you didn't
kill it but i didn't tell me that i
sucked they just were like cool thank
you for the internship see you later
when you audition for a show do they
tell you that you don't get it
i don't know do they let you know you
sucked by not calling back
oh okay well then i guess i sucked i
just don't know how i sucked because
you're asking me what okay
what the [ __ ] do you want so
you're what
47 now [ __ ] off i knew that was coming
you piece of [ __ ] so and you know like
every phase in life that you get better
at right you look back and you go oh i
wasn't as good as i thought it was
so you're telling me
at 49
that the [ __ ] you that you're
still admiring the work you put in at
22. no i keep trying to tell you can i
explain myself god damn it yeah hurry up
okay
so
when i worked at the bank i was really
focused on like climbing up the
corporate ladder i knew i wanted to be
like some type of suit wearing [ __ ] you
know what i mean yeah so i wanted that
you look good in suits too thank you
very much i
angry
but
um compliments aside i
was really focused on climbing right
so i want to say about year two to three
i was like in business banking i was
working with like high profile um um
business owners and stuff
but at the tail end of that right before
i started to like when i [ __ ] left i
was so overworking there because i had
been introduced to the life of wait uh
overworking or over
working i'm over you're over that job
gotcha gotcha yeah
um so i was introduced to you your
lifestyle this alternative way of living
that i was just like wait
what the [ __ ] am i doing here at this
job
and then at that point it was literally
from
from night and day
i was just like boom i'm out like
mentally just checked out i didn't give
a [ __ ] so hard that once i put in my two
weeks notice literally the next day
maybe the second day um my manager was
like hey you know what um it's okay if
you just don't finish out your two weeks
here because you're really influencing
the other staff and no one else wants to
like everyone is just rubbing out like
you're rubbing off on everyone and no
one really wants to work like everyone's
work ethic went
that happened at the beginning of the
two weeks yeah holy [ __ ] yeah so i got
paid for like
not showing up to work because i was
just like so checked out for that last
week what was the difference like what
what what's uh stellar geo and then
what's like putting in the two weeks geo
um so stellar geo was always on time
which is obviously baseline right but
you would be surprised how many people
don't do that um i was always going
above and beyond to like
get new accounts uh i was coming up with
different events like i didn't see
anyone really be as proactive as me i
was like hey i noticed that this
business is over here this business over
here is it okay with you manager if like
i can have this block of time and i want
to put together an event and like be out
there and she'd be like yo that's tight
she's like well who what what um like
staff do you want to take with you and
i'd be like oh i want that guy and that
guy what would other people do did you
stay in the branch they were just very
passive oh so that's why like every
quarter i was getting all these like
hefty bonuses
um
that later i would have to [ __ ] use
because i would always crash my [ __ ]
car but besides the point um every
quarter i was getting bonuses just
because i was hitting all my goal goals
and then some
um
whereas everyone else was just like
doing what was listed on the job
description you were going above and
beyond yeah i mean there was like there
was like
a couple people i guess like me and
maybe another person or like two other
people
um but no one like i i mean i'm just
like focused on myself right like i'm
just looking at other people and what
they're doing and i'm like man i'm just
trying to get i'm just trying to stack
my chips i'm trying to just keep
climbing what made you have that like
ambition
um
i've always had this idea of things that
i want which tend to be material just
because that's all i really knew at the
time um so the first one
was my car right like i wanted to get a
car i wanted to buy it on my own so i'm
like what does it take for that
um lucky for me i qualified for
financial aid so i was like sick that's
that's where my money's going yeah like
because for me car equals freedom
freedom equals exploring and then i
already had like my checklist of what i
wanted in my life right like i had my
timeline of um i want to climb the
corporate ladder
i want to be a businesswoman
i wanted to be financially stable
then at that point i wanted to meet
someone get married buy a house have
kids boom life done right so i had like
this checklist of things that i wanted
to do um
and the first step for that was
freedom like driving around like uh
exploring different areas in my city
outside of my city all that stuff so
that was the first one and then once i
got that car i was like um my next car
that i want is i wanted a honda cause
everyone like so i got a geo
ironically enough
geoprism i know
um they don't make those no more
no they don't good and every time i know
it was such a reliable car though really
yeah it was stick shift it was probably
the name no one liked it
what do you mean everyone likes a geo
i never heard that phrase before
geography geometry
i always hear people saying they hate
those subjects
all three of those subjects that's true
well that's why they probably like me so
much because i'm like the opposite of
those
say some [ __ ]
so were you like this in elementary
school like ambitious where you're like
nah i don't i don't think so so you
weren't stellar though as a kid no you
just told me you're stellar as a kid
huh i just told you yeah i was like what
about at like second grade class
historian were you crushing it and
they're like you said all that [ __ ] i
didn't hear any of that
what yeah
i was here but i guess i didn't hear
that no what did you say because i was
telling you i was asking because you're
sitting like two jobs right two jobs i
was like all jobs i was like down
are you kidding me this time yes down to
the second grade class historian did you
see do you [ __ ] see this [ __ ]
fourth place right here
do you see all my report cards up there
they're [ __ ] shitty okay i need to
read we need i need to re-ask you
everything then because i don't know if
we've been having the same conversation
i thought you just met in like working
i said all jobs down to the second grade
class historian or universal music
literally any person goes i bestow this
responsibility upon you any
responsibility in school
you weren't in charge of yourself
putting the hand balls away
okay so then okay so what so when you
just said i crushed it my whole life you
didn't question i thought you meant
specifically work so that's my mistake
can you clarify the whole thing just for
the record because i'm confused now um
so i thought you just meant in work like
me as a working person okay so now you
with mine you understand you can
identify the whole thing um so
what did you suck ass at and what were
you good at school and i'm good at
hustling
that was hustle in school not really i
didn't see it as a so i think i was so
deprived of like human interaction that
i just saw school as a way to hang out
with friends or as a way to just see
people because like in my the way i grew
up
is um grew up in the hood my mom luckily
was a teacher in a really good
neighborhood and um because of that i
was able to go to school there because
you know how usually schools you you
can't go
um outside of like your zip code or like
your area in which you live so the area
in which i live the school i'm supposed
to go to is [ __ ] ghetto uh and my mom
was just like now we're not having that
so my mom did a really good job of
protecting me from all of that where
unfortunately for me growing up i was
just inside my house the whole time like
i couldn't go out in my front yard even
like outside of my gate to play with
anyone i didn't know any of my neighbor
kids like um so it was like school was
like the only time i could like hang out
so when i was there i was [ __ ]
distracted because i'm like all i wanted
to do was just talk to my friends so i
was always the kid and i'm sure you can
relate to this um that was like in a
desk facing the [ __ ] wall because i
wouldn't shut the [ __ ] up um so like
yeah i didn't really care for like
grades or anything we did horrible in
school absolutely horrible
yeah so i think like maybe um
like elementary intermediate because my
parents had such a heavy hand in my
studies
that i was just average like i wasn't
above average or i'm like a 4.0 but i
was probably like a three point
two three point five you know 25 is
pretty good like okay then maybe 3.2 or
3.0 3.2 then aren't you sure you're not
you're
it's not 2.5 or something
2.5 that was high school like high
school was when it was like
[ __ ] because i think 2. 2.5
is uh is a mexican 3.0 [ __ ] off dude i'm
serious no it's not i've never seen so
many mexicans cheering it's not a
mexican thing okay it's gonna get 3.0
and then they got straight a's no they
don't stop it that's not even true you
don't even hang out with mexicans
i live in the 626. half of it is mexican
yeah but you only kicked it with asian
people
no
i sit next to mexicans in my class
because i can smell them they smell
[ __ ] bummed i know the laundry is
turning really good the soap the cologne
we got the cents online so what's the
biggest difference between um
the crushing it geo and then the two
weeks one then
uh and like let's say you put yourself
in a power position would you have fired
that one like immediately
fired the two weeks one yeah yeah of
course what were you doing that's so
different like i just didn't i just
really didn't care about [ __ ] if someone
comes in i'd be like like you could just
even see it in my posture
like i walk in and i'm already like
i didn't want to engage with anyone like
um i mean i was still kind of
professional you know but like i wasn't
giving attitude or anything anything
like that but i definitely like it was
just such a
stark difference what's the difference
um that like what i was saying like i
would wake up hey good morning what's up
i'm trying to like talk to everyone i'm
trying to like
um have like really engaging
conversations with like any of my
business clients so that i can see if i
can get more business
um i was always trying to strategize
like with my bosses and just trying to
be like hey okay so then who was like
the tops out like picking their brain
all the time
um
and um
uh like even like investment bankers i
was always trying to learn from them and
talk to them and just be like okay well
what is your what are your guys's
strategies like where do you go from
here like just constantly trying to find
my ends and anything
um
and then just even with my co-workers
right like even just trying to encourage
them i was always trying to be really
positive like um
like trying to set the example
uh and then the two weeks one was just
like
quiet more reserved
um did you close any deals or close
anything no during the two weeks no i
didn't give a [ __ ]
yeah i was just like i'm out of here
see a loser did you feel guilty for like
maybe not then but afterwards did you
feel guilty for like never really yeah
so like the bank that i worked for was
so [ __ ] corporate yeah that like no
one really got close to you like that
and you didn't really get close like
it's just so massive like you don't
really get it's not like a small
business where you know directly who
the owner is and you like you have
actual conversations with them bazillion
branches yeah it's a bazillion branches
and just a bazillion steps to get to
anyone that's like and everyone just
seems so fake in corporate i see you
know like everyone is just like everyone
semi checked out so chipper and like
[ __ ] like goodie two shoes and you
think you're so funny and i'm just like
bro this feels so fake i see um so there
was
there was really no personality to a lot
of
anyone that
from above that came down like it just
felt like it was um slightly demeaning a
little bit
because yeah because it was just like um
i don't know maybe it could be my own
insecurities at that time but like it
just didn't feel genuine
you know like it was all about sales it
was all about the numbers and stuff and
i was for that right because i'm like
i'm gonna get commission off of this
let's go let's write it out but it got
to the point where there was just no
heart or anything in it so that's why
when i checked out like i knew no one
was gonna give a [ __ ] about me anyway
like i was just a number um yeah i was
just an id like if i left
it wasn't gonna make a difference
yeah i see yeah
my worst job ever
um that i'm like man i did a really
really bad job
was uh i think my first like actual
legit job in high school
i think i was 16 or 17
and at that time i think everyone's kind
of material driven in high school
because you don't know anything else
that's bigger than yourself or like your
passion well what are your influences
right yeah your buddies well that or
just like these [ __ ] pop stars oh
yeah for me i didn't give a [ __ ] about
the pop stars for me it was more about
my buddies
and i'm like oh man so you bought like
that civic
oh i saw him like put a sound system in
oh they bought an exhaust i'm like dude
how much is that exhaust like 300 bucks
i'm gonna do what'd you get 300 bucks
from that's a lot of money yeah i worked
here and then so i had one of them
hooked me up with the interview and it's
for this telemarketing place so uh
and it was like a one day tryout so it's
like an eight hour tryout but it wasn't
very stringent because like i think in
that first day there might have been
like
i don't know maybe like 12 people showed
up and it was like a group hiring
process is everyone 16 or is it just
like a range of range i'm 16 50 year old
lady
some ex-con guy with tattoos on his face
just all his minimum wages look 16 i
feel like you look [ __ ] like 13 or 9
i don't know i don't know i thought i
was a man were you bald either balder
had bangs you know that 90s look
what are these bangs you keep talking
about because i just keep picturing
these two little [ __ ] cockroaches
like you would be like like i would
shave like like the rest of it is like
this and then i'll like slick it back oh
okay okay okay those are bangs got it
just the front right just yeah
regardless of how you style it you just
only had bangs got it the back was like
a little short crew cut and then like
fade you know got it got it yeah so it
was like um
all walks of life minimum wage i think
was like seven bucks maybe 625 at the
time goddamn you remember i forgot
something like that
and um
and i just thought the hiring process
was so easy it was like
like it was just basic high by hey if
someone wants to hang up or if they go
like this what do you go uh
what do you uh what do you do like how
do you reconcile the situation
and the most sad was there's this older
lady i think that she really needed a
job
but she would just say the dumb as [ __ ]
and then i'm like
at that point give me an example at that
um
man it would be like um like let's say
let's say uh okay it'll be like
um hello hi uh hi i'm calling on behalf
of honda and we'd like to conduct a
survey on uh the 2002 crvs and on my
record it shows that you own one yeah i
do um could i get some uh can i conduct
the survey with you yeah i'm concerned
okay so yeah there is there has been
this recall for airbags i just wanted to
know if your airbag if it had any type
of issues
um they've never deployed no
um does your airbag light ever go on
no so be calls like that right which is
live calls um but we just did it
like a uh
like an acting one yeah before you go on
a live call and the main thing was just
like you always want to try twice at the
minimum so if someone hangs up on you
you give them the benefit of the doubt
that the line cut so you'd always call
back hey i'm sorry i lost you uh
whatever and they try to bring up the
conversation if they hang up on you
again then you're just you get it yeah
okay cool we're being rude or whatever
yeah so uh the lady would just wouldn't
know what to do wouldn't know how to
bring the conversation back up even
though she was literally given a script
oh like there's a literal script for
every every company because we're it's a
outsourced telemarketing company
you get scripts for like toasters phones
cars like just conducting random surveys
or whatever right
and uh
she would just didn't know what to do
free she couldn't think on the fly yeah
and i felt bad because at the end of the
eight hour like group hiring because
it's kind of like an audition like four
hours class lunch and the four hours
like let's
put it into to test
and she cried on her way out because she
didn't make it
and that that was when i was like you
know before as a kid like growing up
super asian um my parents didn't really
want me to work because they want me to
focus on my studies i was gonna ask you
like how did you get that at 16 yeah
they wanted me focus on my studies i
lost your job a lot of east asians are
like don't work i cover you because if i
cover you you go to a like ivy league
school when you come back
your salary like the return on the
investment is high on that end yeah so
why make pennies now right um but you
know when i was 16 that's already me
getting kicked out of like four
different schools my parents already
gave up on me so i think me wanting to
get it get a job my dad like just
anything just stay out of the [ __ ]
jail yeah my dad's like if you're not
gonna go to school you might as well go
to get a good job do something right
and um but it was really eye-opening and
i'm like man like
i can totally see why it's good to put
your kids into jobs early
because you get to see all walks of life
and that was the first time i think i
felt really appreciative because i was
like dude
this lady is 50 something they have more
skills than her yeah how the [ __ ] is she
ever going to succeed yeah right that's
[ __ ] crazy well anyways i got hired
and um but this is during my raving days
and you know when you get hired and you
don't have seniority they give you the
shittiest hours so the hours i always
got were saturdays at seven come on
that's when the [ __ ] raves are about
to [ __ ] pop off like saturdays at
sunday um seven sundays i said oh and i
was trying to book weekends only because
i was trying to go to school even though
it's so hard because there's all these
raves so i always ditched school but i
wanted to do good and so i would go
party and then i would uh come out of
the rave like four or five a.m and i
would just sleep in the parking lot of
the the telemarketing place and then i
would go and i literally on like an hour
of sleep still kind of got like lockjaw
from the ecstasy up all night you know
and i'm like going in there and i get my
script and then i have my headphones and
you're in a cubicle like literally
that's kind of good though because
you're so empathetic so you can like
really listen and like really sell but
not when you're like on the come down
you're tired of [ __ ] and your mouth is
like has blisters from chewing all night
you know and i have an eight because
like
there's they put meth in ecstasy too so
you're now the hunger is finally coming
you know that feeling you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know that feeling when you're
dehydrated and then the hunger's coming
you're on the come down and you're just
your serotonin is [ __ ] zap it's like
that so i show up there
i'm doing it i'm literally like it's an
auto call or two so it's one of those
where if you hang up the next number on
the leads list boom they call it for you
don't have to press any number
and then unless you want to manually do
it so i'll be like
and then like there how the place is
structured it's like
man it's really good there's cubicles
and a big square
and then there's a control center in the
in the middle
so that boss in the middle can turn
around 360 and look at all the open
cubicles and he can tap into everyone's
phone and hear what they're saying oh
crazy huh that's really cool yeah like i
guess
some people call it micromanaging for me
i would say quality control is extremely
high
and uh with that type of attitude that i
had though there's times where i'm like
okay how do i prop myself up here where
from the back it looks like i'm awake
and how do i like i would try to like
fidget with the phone and see if i can
make it where it's like
like the phone's on dial tone or it's
like busy so if he clicks in it he
doesn't seem like it's it's me it's the
other person and i'd be like this
and i like support myself on the on my
hand or whatever i was literally like
the shittiest employer
yeah how many times so um
my boss was a former cholo
and he's from white fence so you had a
white fence yeah it's like a o-g-o-g
like yeah gang right and it's he's bald
literally tied to white fence on the
back of his head
so the minute i got hired i already
respected him i was oh man this guy's
not from that's where you were right or
this is after your trollo phase this is
after my well after my like gangster
thug face but i knew all the hoods like
just of the sgv and so when i saw that
i'm like okay this guy like he's for
real i can't pull fast one and he would
try to talk very professional with his
channel yeah yeah i know i could already
hear him but what's dope is
he earned that manager position so he's
one of those guys hey let me talk to you
like like you know like he's still like
he established the way it needs to be
you know
and then so he caught me sleeping once
sleeping twice i'm caught you sleeping
yeah
and then uh then he would like one time
i was sleeping and i think he was fed up
he was like
bart threw my headset
so he didn't even come and like tap on
me yeah i think he was listening in and
he just talked and goes bar come here
and then he was like hey man uh we don't
need you tomorrow and i was like
[ __ ] in my brain i'm like am i getting
fired that was your first time
this episode of get close is brought to
you by
manscaped summer is here
it's freaking hot and if you're like me
then you got sweaty balls
all the time which is freaking dope of
manscape to come out with these brand
new boxers that they took two years to
design and i'm wearing them right now
and they are the most comfortable
cooling boxers that i know especially
when i was in hawaii i wore them for
sure because it's also humid out there
and i don't know what it is every time
it gets hot and sweaty and humid this
might be tmi it gets kind of itchy down
there and i almost feel like i want to
put a baby powder but then i also don't
want to look ridiculous with baby powder
like falling down my shorts and making
me look all dusty and stuff so i don't
do that but these guys are freaking
awesome because they have all kinds of
technology built into it so they got
like uh it's made out of super soft
fabric they got this trademark jewel
pouch so that you know has that that
perfect support that you need and it's
extremely breathable and then i used
also the lawnmower 4.0 so i shave
everything so just get rid of the whole
jungle down there and the humidity is
gone so if you got a similar situation
like me
here's 20 off your order with free
shipping use the code get close g-e-t
c-l-o-s-e and manscape.com that's 20 off
plus free shipping with the code get
close at
manscaped.com once the boxers 2.0
touchers sack you'll never go back
this episode of get close is brought to
you by
expressvpn did you know that if you're
surfing online and you're searching
stuff
even if you're in incognito mode that
your internet service provider can still
track all of your activity and it
doesn't matter what mode you're in or
how many times you clear your browsing
history your internet service provider
can still see every single website
you've ever visited so that's why if you
care about your privacy you wanna get
expressvpn honestly as soon as i turn on
my computer
i turn on expressvpn
before i go online because i don't want
any ads i don't want anything being sold
to me i don't want anything uh that is
affecting my online experience that i am
not in control of so expressvpn also
keeps all of your information secure by
encrypting a hundred percent of your
data with the most powerful encryption
available most time i don't even have it
on because i literally click it and it's
just running in the background doesn't
bug me one bit
and expressvpn is also available on all
of your devices phones computers even
your smart tv so there's no excuse for
not using it
protect your online activity today with
the vpn rated number one by business
insider and if you use this exclusive
link
expressvpn.com get close you can get an
extra three months for free on a
one-year package that's
s e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p dot com slash get
close expressvpn.com
get close to learn more secure your
online experience
these days who knows who's watching
hackers i just don't trust anybody so
you want to get on this expressvpn.com
slash get close yeah because like
[ __ ] loser i've never been fired you
piece of [ __ ] there's no movies they go
you're fired but in real life no one
says those words please tell me you had
like a little box with like a [ __ ]
plant and [ __ ] no because every time you
go in it's a different cubicle i know
dude but i just want i wish that could
have been you because i've never been
fired i don't know what that feels like
yeah but this whole
like oh and i would show up in my rave
clothes
describe that because i didn't i didn't
live through that phase so like either a
baggy ass pants baggy shirt but if i
wore a really baggy white shirt you know
you're laying on the floor so there's
like a piece of gum stuff shut the [ __ ]
up
disgusting or if i wore a bandana
underneath my hat like i'm like [ __ ]
half drenched over here or i might have
like some a [ __ ] pacifier residue or
some [ __ ] like it's just
i could assume i look disgusting because
after you go to a rave the first thing
you want to do is take a hot shower and
melt everything off yeah but i went to
work like that
and that was like the worst
uh what's the dress code like it didn't
matter okay because you're not facing my
manager's from white fence and they
dress literally like a child
like a cholo yeah i mean it doesn't
matter big ass ben date i mean you're on
the phone so i don't think there was a
dress code yeah yeah i don't know how
professional they wanted you not true
but yeah that was my cuz you know if you
dress a certain way then you carry
yourself a certain way so if they make
you come up you know not that they would
but like in a buttoned shirt then you're
probably going to sit upright because
it's just uncomfortable you know what i
mean true yeah that makes sense because
uh i ended up
working for a as much as i hated like
telemarketing ended up working for a
mortgage company later on it makes sense
what other [ __ ] experience do you
have which is on the phone and uh you
have to have um
a dress shirt and tie see yeah it's
mindset baby yeah it was a mindset okay
go ahead
yeah so that was like my worst
performing and i would that's theirs
that's the job that you know like when
you're looking at like your best
performing jobs you're like all right
that's not making it on the resume no
references to that one no references no
need to even know that existed dude
so the closest i have to that feeling
is when i was told
um by my coach so this is uh my junior
year in high school
freshman
okay let me let me backtrack so like
elementary intermediate school or middle
school um
my parents were always checking up on my
grades they were just on my ass right so
even with all that i was still an
average ass student right like a's and
b's okay if i got a c holy [ __ ] i was in
trouble but like a's and b's primarily
um
when i went to high school i had a
little bit more freedom freshman year
maybe the first semester or quarter
semester right um i was still i was
still pretty good like in the threes
second quarter like lower threes third
quarter fourth quarter senior sophomore
year like my grades just [ __ ] tanked
1.0
uh like what made it tank so hard i just
i didn't give a [ __ ] like i just wanted
to hang out like i would ditch class i
was [ __ ] smoking weed like i was just
everywhere else except in school like i
was physically there but mentally just
i just want to have a good time um
and i knew that
um because i had seen my sister be the
example i knew that after
uh college without question i mean uh
after high school without question i'm
going to college and to get into college
you're either taking s.a.t or you go
from like jc up to like um four-year of
uh four years university
so then um the end of my like the fourth
quarter or semester of my sophomore year
i was like dude like i need to change
this [ __ ] like this is i'm a [ __ ]
loser right now and i felt really shitty
so then
um
that's when i wanted to start applying
for sports and like uh during that
summer like i i tried out i made the
team
um but i was still kind of one foot in
one foot out like where i'm like [ __ ] i
still want to hang out like i mean i'm
just picking myself up from being a
[ __ ] super loser
so i didn't
the first semester second semester maybe
of my junior year i couldn't get my
grades high enough but i was really into
volleyball like [ __ ] it was so fun i had
my group of friends all the girls were
super cool they also like were kind of
bad so i was like sick i get the best of
both but i just knew my my life was
gonna now be in like upper trend upward
trend
and i was so tight with the coach and
the coach really liked me i really liked
her
and um my grades came back and i think i
was like like at a two point i don't
know whatever the threshold is i was
like right beneath it
and she was like i'm so sorry but you
can't you can't play this semester like
i can't let you play i remember one of
the um
the speeches we would get from our
coaches in high school would be like
you're
a student athlete
student comes first yeah yeah same does
that happen to me too yeah and it was
[ __ ] soul-crushing because like she's
not trying to kick me off the team but
like she has to yeah so like i was just
so rejected and so heartbroken and i was
like what the that was like my lowest of
the lows that i had felt at that point
i'm like [ __ ]
like this is a sport how can i not be in
a [ __ ] sport like i should be able to
just [ __ ] be on this team and i just
was like
[ __ ] i'm a shitty [ __ ] human right
now
and i like never wanted to feel that
again did you get your grades back up so
you can oh absolutely yeah yeah
absolutely but um
but yeah yeah and then after like my
senior year and stuff i played but it
was [ __ ] did you feel like that did
you feel like super rejected or you were
like
no white fence boss
i get it you should have kicked me out
sooner um it's hard to say i don't know
if i was like in a really deep deep
state of depression
uh because you know um
it's it's kind of like i think
everything's relative right
so when you're like
balling
and like you know when you watch like
those nfl documentaries and then they're
like man i have the world i had a
private jet um i lost my mansion now are
you comparing yourself to an nfl
no um and then they're like um i had a
private jet i had like bentleys and
stuff
and now i just gotta drive my lexus
and everyone's like
right but it's relative
and i think it's relative on the other
end too
where i think i was so [ __ ] depressed
from my parents splitting up getting
kicked out of like 20 million schools so
getting kicked out of school is like
getting firing to the worst it's like
naughty not it's because it's not just
um you got rejected from your own
community yeah it's not just you're
fired
the equivalent is you're fired and
you're not welcome in this industry ever
again and
your entire parents know that
because when you get fired it's just by
yourself when you get expelled you go to
the district office and the district has
to expel you
you know and
um
most people don't even know where the
[ __ ] the district office is for this
school i'm familiar with every single
district that i've been a part of
because every single time i got in so
much trouble it had to get escalated
beyond the principle most people don't
even know who's past the principle you
know i know superintendent exactly but i
know and i know the students because of
my mom and i know who the superintendent
is like on a regular basis which is not
[ __ ] normal that's not normal they're
supposed to be caring about district
budgets and [ __ ] like that and they're
meeting with this kid he's a problem
child um anyway so i was like in such a
downward
uh trend
that i think when i got fired it was
just another
you know it was it wasn't like
oh i was overdue for that anyway yeah i
wasn't like a regular kid if i was a
regular kid and you get fired from your
first job i think it would crush you
yeah
but i think i was already so um
i've been [ __ ] slammed on the floor
and i think even me applying for the job
is me just trying to get up a little bit
and it just it just didn't work so i
just ended up like falling back down you
know
damn so it didn't like like that old
lady that 50 whatever you old lady that
didn't make it the first day she was
bawling
when he told me like um
you don't need to come back tomorrow i
was like
i guess i'll be selling some drugs jokes
on you [ __ ] i'm gonna make more
money you know
damn i've never felt that but i'm not
surprised that you like
went through this [ __ ] because your life
is so abnormal
there's like no [ __ ]
i don't know how you [ __ ] relate to
anyone to be honest with you i think
that's why i relate to everybody because
you've been oh like
my story relates to other people or i my
heart relates to other people's lives uh
no one
like
your story is like so this is everyone
like there's a baseline yeah
and everyone's story is kind of like
along this baseline right like there's
some like
outliers here and there but bart is like
over here yeah like you just cannot
relate with all these other people oh i
see or they can't relate with you they
can't relate with me but i relate with
everyone because of how much stuff i've
been through so i understand i'm like oh
man like um you think you have it's
tough oh i'm trying getting out and
[ __ ] kicked out of 20 schools
which is kind of cool but you're not
like that that's not relating no no i
know it's kind of cool that you're not
like that yeah but i can see why you
consider a lot of people [ __ ] yeah
yeah
because you're like it's not that bad
it could get worse
it can get really working i've been
there and out of the worst i think i had
it the best
so even as bad as i had i'm very very
grateful
you know like i banged
but i didn't die
i didn't go to jail
i don't have any bullet holes i don't
have a bullet hole through my [ __ ]
face
you know like um
i've rubbed shoulders with the worst
but i with the worst yeah but i've um
what's the worst
give me an example people that do those
kind of things
like shoulders like my yeah like my prom
date she um
my
my prom date ended up joining a
uh
female
gang
and the initiation
is like a 12 person train on her by the
the male counterpart of it
so she had 12 dudes [ __ ] yeah
you know i mean like that's like
and then you and then i was serious i
was in that world wait yeah yeah but
where but i'm i'm 15 right i'm in that
world and you were like that's ty yeah
and i'm like that's [ __ ] dope she's
[ __ ] hard
she didn't let no man own her she owned
12 dudes
right she was hot
15 she's probably 15 yeah
she got raped
that's rough dude i don't know if she
got raped she wanted it
god damn i mean that's just another
world i don't know thank god to my
parents because i'm literally around all
of that like i've heard
um like that so that's what i'm saying
right yeah
where like
um that you didn't get the worst of it
you got the best when i when i
come back out of my deep depression into
normal life yeah that's when i look back
and go what the [ __ ] that is like i
can't imagine taika being 15 and then
he's exposed to that he comes you know
what happened to my my female classmate
you know what i mean yeah or like uh
man i'm so grateful i was sheltered or
just that kind of world you know yeah
like imagine like uh taika is 15 he has
to go to a funeral
like that kind of stuff because of gang
related yeah i get it just that world
like not even getting like uh like
every school had the 15 year old would
have like prom what whatever drunk
driving racing smash did you know yeah
and then like um because i'm in that
world those things are
are people i personally knew and then
there are um
recurring instances
it's not just like oh there's that one
time the craziest story i ever heard in
my high school was this it was no my
buddy this this week next week this the
other week me you know it was like
like like that
you are lucky you didn't get swallowed
up by that because it's so easy
right like you had the recipe
to be that like you're smart
um your parents are divorced you come
from a very unstable home your parents
are super overbearing like
dude
that's [ __ ] gnarly that's why i'm
saying you need to write a goddamn book
or goddamn story because you're just not
normal you're not the average person
yeah that is wild so like as close as
like literally as close as i was to
literally all that stuff i gotta stop
saying literally so goddamn it's
probably happening next door
lit yeah for sure
lit um for sure it's happening next door
like my mom i i
remember so many [ __ ] like uh
instances where
i was exposed to it but because i was so
sheltered i didn't understand what was
happening at the time
it's now in retrospect when i look at it
i'm like yo that is some hood behavior
like i remember one time um
we lived in the front house
and we had like a wire fence so all it
is is like a little gate you like those
ones that you latch up and then it just
like swings in or out right
um and then we had the bushes along the
alley that like cover up that alley and
it's like they're thick
so i remember i was just kind of playing
there and then my my dad or my brother
comes and they're like
um they're just kind of looking at these
bushes and they're like joe come over
here and then like you just see a guy
run out like run out of these bushes
because he's trying to get away from
someone he was like in our [ __ ] on
our property and
your brothers and sisters i don't
remember at that point because i was
just so little yeah but nobody knows who
that is um our house has gotten broken
into but that was normal um and it was
probably by one of our neighbors and we
kind of knew who it was but he was just
on cocaine all the time because when i
was growing up cocaine was a [ __ ]
um our neighbors next door always sold
drugs or meth
uh i think it was cocaine maybe meth
then because
expensive when we grew up methodization
okay then it's meth um
um
yeah like breaking into our [ __ ] um
like being shot at like literally god
damn it i gotta use a better word but
like honestly uh like every week someone
was getting shot up like our house had
so many bullet holes okay that sounds
exaggerated but like our front gate had
bullet holes i still see them um nice
little souvenirs
yeah or like there were nights
especially on the weekends where you
would hear
people blasted music but then getting in
fights at the end of it
so like the neighborhood kids we knew
that like you can get up and start
looking on you know the apartment lawns
because i live like next to nothing but
like apartments and stuff um that like
you're gonna find a bunch of [ __ ] on the
on the grass that's crazy because um
you lived in it like geographically deep
in it and it never touched you
your parents did a crazy good job
sheltering you yeah amazing like it
never
this was my life uh i would wake up in
the morning get ready for school go
our car was parked in a garage we had a
garage luckily
um get in the car garage opens get out
garage door closes we start just driving
to my school which is on the other side
of town we're not even in the same town
another town way better different city
yeah
10 15 minute drive
um
go to school after school
then i'd probably do like an
extracurricular like either dance or art
or sports eventually and then come back
home
do homework eat dinner knock out
that was it
like i was not allowed to go outside i
wasn't doing any of that like i could
never leave my
the gate my fence any of that like it
was just there
so that's why i was just like [ __ ] i
need human contact
you know what's crazy is on the flip
side my day in the life
of when i was like 15 or 16
would be me
waking up at a homie's house
um having slept there for like three or
four days already because we've been
raving non-stop and then
one of our homies houses that um we
slept at the most
his older brother and his cousins and
all their friends they're like oh geez
and then by og's i mean
they're probably like 26 27 so that's
really og two people that are like 16 or
17. and they've all been in jail
and we're
like they'll bring home rental cars like
minivans and the kids the youngsters
we're reupholstering the car so that we
can stuff pills into where the stuffing
used to be so that we can traffic the
drugs across state lines and that was so
normal
and one of the dudes that was in there
um he was like one of the goofiest dudes
and uh he was like triple o g to all of
us because he was a known cop killer
so he's one of those dudes that one i
don't even know he was if he was legal
if he was an illegal immigrant from
cambodia or vietnam or laos or wherever
but you know like the southeast asian
gangs are [ __ ] crazy
and so this guy is one of those dudes
where um if they ever find out who he is
they have like that hidden blue code
where we're just shooting them on site
regardless of evidence because this guy
has taken out so many of of the brothers
in blue and that was like the people
that we looked up to i'm like oh him oh
he's like triple o g um
that's crazy yeah and that that was the
world damn you know and then they would
be like all right cool uh we got this
van we're gonna go to a rave in this
state and then we'll roll through that
state and then all these dudes i mean
they're the guys also helping me get
into lifting because they're all like
jacked and we would go and then they'll
be like here here's like 20 pills 50
pills just go sell it um whatever you
make keep it
like they're like super so they really
took care of us too because they're
selling by the thousands ten thousands
you know
and
that was like
our typical life that we were in that's
cute i like how you think they're taking
care of you but they're not they're just
grooming you
because they're like yeah yeah 100 like
why would i get i'm going to be like how
quickly can this kid move some [ __ ] make
his connections hopefully he stays in
this gang he [ __ ] better stay in this
[ __ ] gang and now he works for me
of course this is my life outside of
game life
that's crazy that's that that life is me
going hey i'm done with my gang life
it's all about love now so that would
sell something so that was my raver face
so that so that to me was like
me not even involved in the underworld
isn't that crazy the perspective of like
when you're that young i'm like oh no
these are just like doing homie favors
now like me unpacking like this the
phone and the car knowing you're still
in the underworld yeah without knowing
i'm still like doing that kind of stuff
i just didn't my perspective it's just
because i wasn't actively [ __ ] people
up or like robbing houses i'm like oh
this is uh
this is cool like this is i'm not
hurting nobody i'm just taking these
foam apart and before we turn it back to
hertz i'm going to put the foam parts
right back in i don't even know anything
happen
so the flip to your flip i remember
trying to ask my parents like
oh god and this is the [ __ ] worst and
i'm sure like anyone that's mexican can
relate to this [ __ ] hey mom can i go to
so-and-so's house i don't know ask your
dad [ __ ]
all right wait for my dad to get home
hey dad is it is it okay if i can go to
so-and-so's house and mind you this
these are the friends that my parents
already know because
um my mom needs to know every single one
of my friends their moms where they live
all of that like my mom's very much
involved
and uh my mom my dad will be like well i
don't know what your mom say well she
said ask you i don't know i don't want
to know anything go ask your mom i'm
like [ __ ] right so then finally when
someone says i can hang out it's
literally for like there we go again uh
it's it's gonna be for like an hour or
two what prevented you from sneaking up
or running away from home i was scared
i was so [ __ ] sheltered
i thought the world was gonna [ __ ]
kill me i thought i was gonna get raped
murdered kidnapped trafficked like all
of that bad [ __ ] i thought was gonna
happen to me like i knew nothing outside
of that fence and i just knew there were
a bunch of bad people and i was a hot
commodity
that was it oh yeah and i was just like
ah dude i only snuck out of my house one
time and that's when i was 20 something
and i was so scared i was like holy [ __ ]
i was really scared of like my parents
wow
so yeah so then i'd go to my friend's
house and my mom and that she would talk
to my friend's mom and she would give
her the lowdown like i don't want them
out here i don't want her to do this
like please make sure that like you keep
an eye on them like if we go on school
field trips because my mom's part of
that school district she would know
every single driver every single teacher
every single [ __ ]
ta all of that [ __ ] uh and she'd be like
keep an eye on that one let me know if
she does anything and i'm like [ __ ]
so like my mom had her hand in every
aspect of my life
so yeah i mean i'm grateful now that's
crazy but at that time i'm just like so
regulated that i'm like [ __ ] man let me
[ __ ] do something so now you can see
why i was dying to have a car yeah
because i'm like and and i was dying to
work like i remember in high school i've
never been the kid to be like can you
buy me this give me my business give me
my business because i would just see my
parents work so hard that i'm like i'm
not doing [ __ ] to earn my
keep here like i should be earning my
own money like i just felt guilty asking
for things not that i ever felt poor
which is really ironic
because we definitely weren't like super
poor but we weren't like well off
obviously if i live in the hood right
but um
i always wanted to work because i wanted
to earn my own money and like um
anything that i could do to take care of
myself i would like
do my own laundry like all that [ __ ]
right so like as soon as i could save up
money i'm like the first thing i'm doing
is buying my freedom aka a car
yeah
on the flip side
um i think
one of the best jobs
that i ever did was uh in the marine
corps
i think um one shout out to
my boss
i think he helped me a lot
because he gave me like a really good
framework i think also the marine corps
kind of does but i think the marine
corps framework is so hardcore that it
either burns you out makes you hate it
or makes you excel
it's it's probably those three like most
people they either get out immediately
after their four or six year enlistment
or they go life or they just don't want
to do anything military ever again
but when i by the time i joined the
marine corps i was
18
and and
that's when i was really like i really
got to get my life together so my own
plan when i graduated high school was
join the marine corps
go to community college
um do the whole reserves thing so i can
go to school and do the whole military
thing at the same time
study my ass off get into a really good
four-year university that's my goal like
i really wanted to like turn my life
around
and i so i think although like
it's really hard to go night and day i
definitely had my um
my relapses like my first quarter i
didn't do so good i still like
uh of course ditched and and all that
you know yeah yeah but every time i feel
really guilty and i really almost like
lecture myself like like hold myself
accountable so my first you hold your
own shirt like listen here you [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah like by and like by doing
that i mean like 3.3
which is insanely good to
in high school in high school like one
point something across the board you
know
um but something that i really liked
about the marine corps that made me want
to kill it is um
one of the things that my boss taught me
was you always want to learn your boss's
job
that's how you get promoted and also in
in the marine corps you're paid
according to your rank so if you want to
make more money you need to get promoted
fast so he was like if you want to take
if you can do my job i can trust you i
can work on bigger things i can take my
job my boss's job will all get promoted
together so there's that one mindset i
really liked and the other thing that
you always hear especially when you're a
younger marine is
if you're not busy i'll find work for
you
so you're just always you know like uh
finding some sort of busy work and
there's like almost zero downtime
so like let's say um
so i worked in a supply
and like let's say we got all
the equipment and supplies necessary for
a
a certain exercise right it's like
literally running inventory we get all
that stuff ready and then we have to
always double check like reconcile our
inventory with the budget that we get
every year because we like things have
to get allocated right like if we're
if
can we afford to destroy these five
packs
um because do we have enough money to
buy other five or do we need another
five for something else that we need in
the future that kind of stuff so you're
always like you know cross-checking
these numbers
you had 18
well it's a whole team it's a whole like
your whole life um section right got it
so we'll drew this together with my
friends to compliment you but yeah
you're right you're dumb yeah i'm dumb
with my supply with my boss as my leader
my supply chief as my leader he runs all
this all the stuff
but because he always has take my job
and also stay busy i'll find work for
you
that created this type of mentality
where even when things are perfect how
can i make it perfecter
so after we have like a big goal like
wall-to-wall inventory make sure
everything is set in place and
everything is set
i would still walk through our supply
where all like uh all the shelves of all
of our stuff is and i'm like what's a
faster way we can do
uh to run inventory what's a more
efficient way that we can keep track of
stuff because this time we did our
inventory took us two days can i bring
that down to
one day
and then so like one of the things that
i started doing was i would take things
and i would wrap it in bundles of five
or ten so like let's say if we're going
to count
um
a thousand ammo pouches instead of
counting like literally hey you count
100 i count 100 you count 100 they're
already in groups of 10
and then so now we're just got to count
like all of us just have to count 100
things you know so like we were able to
bring that down is there better ways we
can relabel the warehouse
is there a better way we can have like
the feng shui or the flow of the
warehouse where we notice people they
check in or check out they're always in
this order let's let's uh do it
according to how the new workflow is and
there's constantly is we're improving
the efficiency of stuff
and me constantly wanting to learn more
from my boss so that i can do his job
and uh i ended up picking up sergeant in
like four years in the reserves which is
like
very very very rare uh what is the
average
for that position so at that time um it
was tough to even pick up sergeant at
all in your first enlistment like if you
picked up corporal which is like a
non-commissioned officer which is right
under sergeant you did pretty good
if you could pick up corporal in five
six years that's pretty good
um but i picked up sergeant in four
years i don't think i've ever been that
stellar
really yeah i don't think i i honestly i
feel like i've just been this average
person my whole life oh and it was so
good to the point where
on the end of my enlistment
um they had this thing called end zone
so corporal and sergeant is
non-commissioned officer uh
staff sergeant and above
it's called like a staff
non-commissioned officer so now you
start rubbing shoulders in like the big
board rooms
um so in zone meaning like you have
enough on your resume to even be
considered to go into that side of
things dang i was in zone on my sixth
year and i was offered a bonus to
re-enlist
how much was a bonus
um probably like i don't know like 10
grand a year extra or whatever
um but it was gonna be like
that's how how dope i was doing where
they wanted to keep me as
on to do another year or two you know
but at that time i just had like so much
on my mind like i was at ucla and then i
fell in love with jk and like i was just
like oh i think this was a really good
chapter of my life but i was ready to
move on from both school and the
military yeah
yeah yeah i don't think i've had
anything like that i don't think i've
ever been stellar at anything
so he's been lukewarm the whole time not
too bad not too good yeah i think so
i think i've always just been an average
person no one ever told you man he
[ __ ] smashed at this
not that it i recall or maybe i don't
take compliments but no i don't remember
you don't ever do things and go man i'm
better than everyone at this
no
i never do that really you think you're
the same as everybody um i think we all
have our own strengths like i'll see
other people and i'm like man i can't do
what they're doing
you know but i'm i'm never really going
like
i'm the [ __ ] [ __ ] like i've never had
that mindset oh damn
not that it's good or bad but um
yeah i always feel like i'm like [ __ ] i
don't know enough about this [ __ ] let me
keep like
who else is really good here that i can
like learn oh that person's actually
better than me i perceive it better than
me i'm like okay let me let me see what
i can learn from that person but i don't
ever feel like i'm a like
like outstanding
has there ever been a job where you're
really proud of yourself at
where i'm really proud of myself not
really no really yeah i feel like i can
always do better yeah you can always do
better yeah but i always feel like oh i
did enough to just kind of like
hang in there
yeah
maybe that's what keeps me
striving for it that i'm that i i i'm
always going like yeah this is not good
maybe you're not focusing on the
objectives
like you know the marine corps yeah
um every rank has more benefits
so literally when i get another chevron
and you see me
i could tell you what to do well for me
and also
not only that we could not know each
other i can literally go to another yeah
that's cool because it's a physical
thing that's what i'm saying right so
that's like there's an objective metric
right
or um
in like basketball
like every game i know
i know you scored 10 points i scored 20
points i'm obviously better than you
yeah so for me remember these two jobs i
had the first one was the bookstore
there's nothing really there
right i just thought i was a good seller
because i was just like
uh during the school year people would
come in we would buy back their books
right so then there's this program the
software that you use you like
um
like you scan their ibn number isbn isbn
number and then uh the computer will
like spit out what it costs for you to
buy that book like uh industry
so then i'm like well i don't want to
pay that
so then i would like undercut or like
sell it so that i can make my bosses
money isn't that funny and i wouldn't
get like a cut from that or anything i
would just get this sense of pride where
i'm like yeah
i close that [ __ ] you know um so stupid
but you don't go like hey like other
coworkers how many did you close no
there wasn't other co-workers it's so
small the only time we had co-workers
they were temps because
uh it's only like the first week of
school where it gets nuts what about the
bank job there's no other uh like
bankers like you and you're like well
because obviously you got more bonuses
than everyone else and you got all these
i don't know if i got it more than
anyone else i just knew i had my bonus
like i wasn't sitting there comparing
right weren't you getting invited to a
special disneyland restaurant like i was
isn't that like only like the top
regional or top yeah but i don't know
how many of those got it outside of my
branch right like i know in my branch it
was probably like me and maybe someone
else so that means you knew at your
branch you're the best yeah but at the
same time too i'm like
i don't know i'm i'm just like if no one
else from your branch is going yeah i
just don't think i'm the [ __ ] you know
maybe because i just didn't even really
respect that job where i was just like
this is just a me this is just a
uh like i'm still moving up this is
still entry level for me
you know but you could kill it in first
grade yeah but i wasn't like super
killing like i just didn't feel like i'm
the [ __ ] it was one like sick my hard
work's paying off because i'm getting
bonuses cool i'm gonna keep i'm gonna
keep trying to attack it oh so it was
just like that um i was never really
like comparing or trying to think of
what other people were doing i'm like my
objective is to move out of my house hit
these goals am i getting closer to that
or am i getting further away if i'm
getting further away i'm doing the wrong
thing if i'm getting closer cool and me
getting closer was getting more money so
i'm like sick i'm i'm i'm going down the
path i want to go so i didn't really
care about what anyone else was doing
but i didn't feel like i was like [ __ ]
damn i just felt like i was so tunnel
vision with me trying to hit my own
objectives that if i'm like if i'm
getting closer to that then i'm doing
the right thing that's crazy i don't
know if it's maybe like either
my asian upbringing or maybe just my mom
specifically but ever since i was a kid
like um knowing where i stand was so
important
yeah for sure it's an asian thing and
your mom thinks because like even like
in uh i remember in junior high
they would post the test results
and they would post it on the wall but
have your student id number right
[ __ ] geek so no one would be like i
didn't give a [ __ ] so no one uh it's
anonymous but you know where you're at
and i always have to go look because the
times that i cared
i want to make sure that i'm up there
yeah but the times i don't care i'm like
i already i don't give a [ __ ] anymore
and it's like all the way at the bottom
yeah i don't think i cared because i
just i've always felt so average i felt
so average literally in every part of my
life so i'm like i'm probably in the
middle always
so i'm like what there's no point are
you happy with the success that you have
had then
or do you feel like your success is
average too
um
when i look around and i pull because
i'm such a workaholic and a workhorse
i don't really sit there to think about
that
and it's not until i go back to my
previous life if you will um where i
meet up with old friends or i see where
people from my high school are and just
kind of like the trajectory of their
life
where it seems to be aligned to what my
goals were before being introduced to
the life of youtube and like an
alternative yeah an alternative
lifestyle in entrepreneurship
that's when i'm like oh [ __ ] this is
different
but besides that i don't really sit
there and think about it and think about
how different it is
but it is right like when i when now
having this conversation i'm like look
that is it's not normal at all
but i never think i'm really good
again
i'm average you know interesting
yeah so
um for you you had parents and
culturally
you want to know where you stand um
probably comes even from the asian
school system you know because it's like
you ever all the people want to test
into the best elementary school that's
how early it starts and from the
elementary school you want to test into
the best middle middle school and test
into the best high school so even though
we don't have that system over here my
mom probably carried that culture and
that drive of understanding that you
always got to try to be the best
yeah no and then brought that over here
best was never like a
it was never like heavily enforced like
even for it wasn't even a thing even at
chinese school there was like a singing
competition that my mom entered me into
and then even that feeling and all you
win is a high school it seems like two
like your your um your mom came from a
different like
financial bracket
right even though she is i was gonna say
imported but
imported goods
they paid tariffs for her yeah even
though she did come here from another
country yeah
she came here from people that had money
that were able to afford her ass to be
flown out here you know yeah so like her
mindset is not survival it's more like
they my parents maybe they didn't even
have to survive you know maybe her
parents parents parents survived
and then just generationally my mom's
parents had to survive because they left
a warring
a warring nation oh so then she got it
better so
my mom's college educated which is rare
so your mom is like us oh your mom is
like me
your mom yeah yeah and she moved here by
will which is why her other two siblings
are still over there yeah it's like
she's not a she's not a refugee she
didn't come here to seek a better life
she came here because my dad asked yeah
to marry her whereas like my family like
we are that first generation i see first
generation of like
success or or more than than having to
survive yeah all i see yeah because my
parents came here
teens nothing at all super poor ground
up you know whereas your mom i mean your
dad's also that way ground up yeah my
dad your mom though is not ground up
your mom is super ground grass
pretty good foundation
maybe even like a small little house on
there yeah and now she can go out of
that yeah so that's really dope that's
really fortunate so like when i think
about it like that i'm just like whoa
i've done a lot
it would sound rapid upright
i don't know if you had a follow-up to
that okay
um
yeah but that's not something i really
think about i should i should probably
do some more digging and see why or not
i could just leave it alone
um where do you think you lie now
in what regard what you're asking like
do you think you're in a place now where
you're like
um
you're super killing it or you're just
like it's just it's a different phase
um in my phase now
i don't think i'm killing it at all
yeah you think you're super
but killing it in terms of career
because i think you're killing it as a
husband and a father
thank you
you're welcome
um i think in that regard
i feel like i'm a pretty good husband
and i think i'm a pretty good dad you're
an outstanding husband and you're an
outstanding dad oh thank you mom that's
very cuny yeah i'm not trying to be cuny
dude but i also think i also think like
the bigger the leagues you go
the the bigger the
the galaxy right so like i think like
when you're in a small pond it's like
the top junior high basketball player
does good cool it gets to go to the best
high school now he's no longer the
starting point guard might be a bench
player you know or if let's say he is he
goes to college scholarship right
then he gets to the nba and he's ranked
50. yeah it's like all of a sudden right
and then you go okay all-time
best point guards not even on the list
that's i think where i'm at you know
what i mean yeah so i think like i think
like i crushed it a lot
and then um but as i entered into the
bigger and bigger world so maybe like
early jk when we really cared about
making an impact and doing well on
youtube we used to be on the front page
so that means top 100
channels uh
of uh
of comedy probably top 100 um even asian
american channels right so yeah pretty
up there
and then as we grew the company um
you know everyone's goals are working
and youtube is growing and youtube's
growing right and so some people care
about
where their channel status is
um me and joe really cared about
lifestyle the team so now those
metrics aren't the same metrics that
youtube measures they measure other
things so the youtube keeps growing and
now we're kind of growing sideways
focusing on the which is also a luxury
which is really cool growing sideways
into things that we really care about
yeah right kind of like uh
like who's that chick um
like jessica alba right i i believe
she's a billionaire now or a reese
witherspoon so grease where the spoon is
so yeah look like they're in acting
and then maybe at one point they were
one of the most grossing grossing actors
right
and then they're like you know what i
have another passion and it kind of grew
this way yep so in terms of the acting
world it's dude you're dropping rankings
right there's all these new people
margot robbie whoever all these people
now but then now
they're going and focusing on the other
things that make their own hearts happy
yeah but if you zoom out from a from an
acting perspective
i think same thing where i go so if i'm
viewing our youtube channel in the world
of youtube
very mediocre
um but my heart is extremely full
because i get to spend on time on the
things i really care about which is
being a dad and being a husband yeah
yeah that's super sick and i think it
does that's why i was asking it it does
it does work out like that it depends on
what it is that you're measuring
um but going back to you saying like
it depends on like the world that you're
in
that like you'll feel like the big fish
in a small pond or you'll feel like the
small fish in a big pond and i think
i've always felt like the small fish in
a big pond because i'm getting exposed
to so many things all the goddamn time
that i'm always like
if i ever feel like i'm the big the big
fish i'm like oh [ __ ] i don't need to be
here i need to get out of here because i
know i don't know [ __ ] about [ __ ] or
[ __ ] about [ __ ] yeah that i'm always
going like as soon as i start stunning
like i know what the [ __ ] i'm like like
i'm becoming the head of this group i
need to get out because i'm like i'm a
[ __ ] dumbass yeah so me being the
head of this group no no no no no we're
going downhill baby that's very true
yeah shut up
well damn thank you that was a really
dope question that was that was a really
dope question that i don't really think
about um and it really puts
quite a few things in perspective for me
because i'm going like [ __ ] that's true
like
i've come a long way and i don't really
sit there to really think about that
um so it was really it was really cool
for you to bring that up thank you yeah
i feel like a lot of the answers of the
future
reside in the past okay confucius so um
i like talking about stuff like that
because
it's uh it's cool to share that journey
with lots of people you know like you
remember i told you even like when we
first started dating um just that
interest me like i would read i love
biographies i was reading biography of
like oh i thought like you dating me was
interesting got it no no like uh abe
lincoln baby
um lady gaga i remember you wrote a book
on lady gaga and i was like why i just
really like
i enjoy people's stories like the origin
stories because we
we just like bill clinton you know like
clinton's not even his last name i
believe he took the the name of his
stepdad why yeah you know just stuff
like that where i i was
um
i was just always like interested in how
people became who they are yeah because
we view people
and then we have this pedestal status
for them and it's just taken for granted
but
everyone climbed their own pedestal yeah
so it's cool to hear people's stories
how they got there and stuff like that
and it's
it's it's really inspiring and it's
something that i've always liked even as
a kid i just love hearing stories like
that yeah if um i probably shouldn't
promote this because i just want to be
selfish but i also do like enjoying uh
any type of of enrichment and anyone
that cares to listen to me is how i
built this i love listening to that
podcast because it brings in the top
heavy hitters of any and every industry
in fortune 500 companies um and just any
company we've ever heard of and they'll
bring in you know the ceo the founder or
whatever of it and then they're like how
did you build this and then they they
walk you through all of their trials and
tribulations and it's so relatable
because like as a fellow entrepreneur
i'm just like oh my god i'm right there
right now and oh [ __ ] this is very
normal okay cool so yeah now we get to
contribute to that which is really sick
dope and on that note i'm not even going
to ask you if you have anything else to
contribute because i already know your
goddamn answer
thank you so much for listening um i
hope you got some really dope gems from
this episode please let us know in the
comments below if there's anything else
that you you see us doing or not talking
about that you do want us to talk about
until then we'll see you next week bye
bye